this month high school students are
going to get to learn what it takes to
join the field of nursing certainly an
important field it is all taking place
at unlv school of nursing it's the third
annual nurse camp mary jane velias
joining us now live at the unlv shadow
lane campus mary jane so important
because we know there's a shortage it's
a critical need
absolutely it was just so cool to see
all these students just happy to be here
really excited to learn a lot more high
school juniors and seniors work and
train alongside unlv students and nurses
to get a first hand look at what nurses
go through every day this is a one week
interactive camp with three different
sessions high school students are
participating in a number of activities
like cpr wound care and so much more
with nurse shortages across southern
nevada and in the united states the call
for more highly trained nurses is so
important so this gives students a
chance to learn more about a future
career and observe the nursing field
through a clinical setting
personally for me i didn't
fall in love with nursing until the
first time i was in the hospital
actually doing it so i understand how
you know practicing in person can kind
of give you a better idea it gives me
such a greater purpose
and it gives me something to actually
look forward to each day
because i know at the end of the day i
could quite possibly save a life
this camp is such a great way to show
how much of a role nurses play in our
community each session will end with a
recognition ceremony and that nurse camp
is open to high school juniors and
seniors and even recent grads but there
is limited spots available right now
with the last session ending on july
29th reporting live mary jane balleza
live local now